what advice
would you give to a
young person today with a bit of fire in
their eyes high school student college
student
thinking about what to do with their
life maybe advice about
career or bigger advice about life in
general
well first read fundamentals because
there i've tried
i've tried to to uh give some coherent
uh deep advice that's the fundamentals
10 keys
to reality by train cool check so that's
a good place available
everywhere if you want to learn what i
like but i can tell you
uh the uh is there an audiobook
yes there is yeah i think
it's like i can give three pieces of
wise advice
that i think are generally applicable
one is to cast a wide net
to really look around and see
what looks promising what catches your
imagination
uh and
and promise yeah and those you have to
balance those two things you can have
things that catch your imagination but
don't look promising in the sense that
the questions aren't ripe
or uh but and and things that you
in part of what makes things uh
attractive
is that whether you thought you liked
them or not is this if you can see that
there's ferment and new ideas coming up
that become that's attractive in itself
so uh when i started out i thought i was
and when i was an undergraduate i
intended to study philosophy or
questions of how mind emerges from
matter but
i thought that that wasn't really right
timing isn't right yet the ripe was the
timing wasn't right for the kind of
mathematical thinking and
conceptualization that i really enjoy
him and good at
but uh so that that's one thing cast a
wide net look around
uh and that's that's
a pretty easy thing to do today because
because of the internet you can look
you can look at all kinds of things of
you have to be careful though because
there's a lot of crap
also but uh you you know you you can
sort of tell the difference if you
if you do a little digging uh the the uh
so don't don't don't settle on just you
know what your thesis advisor tells you
to do or what your teacher tells you to
do
look for yourself and and and get a
sense of what
what what seems promising uh not what
seemed promising 10 years ago or
uh the uh uh so that's one
uh another thing is to
is kind of complementary to that well
they're all complimentary
complimentary to that is to uh is to
read
history and read the masters of the
history of ideas and masters of ideas
i'd benefited enormously
from as as as in early in my career from
reading
in physics einstein
in the original and feynman's lectures
as they were coming out
and darwin you know these
you can you can learn what it in galileo
you can learn
what it is to wrestle with difficult
ideas and how great minds did that
you can learn a lot about uh style
how how to ex write your ideas up and
express them in in clear ways and also
just just a couple that with uh
i also enjoy reading biographies and
biographies yes
similarly right like so it gives you the
context the context of the human being
that created those
right and brings it down to earth in the
sense that you know it was really human
beings who did this
it's not uh and and they made mistakes
and
yeah uh i also you know i also got
inspiration from bertrand russell who
was a big hero and h.g wells and yeah
so uh read read the masters
make contact with great minds and when
you are
sort of narrowing down on a subject
learn about the history of the subject
because
that really puts in context what you're
trying to do and
and also gives a sense of community and
grandeur to the whole enterprise
uh and then the third piece of advice is
complementary to both those which is
sort of
to uh to get
the basics under control as soon as
possible
so if you want to do theoretical work in
science
you know you you you have to learn
calculus multivariable calculus complex
variables group theory
nowadays you have to be highly computer
literate
uh if you want to do experimental work
you also have to be computer literate
then you have to learn about electronics
and
optics and instruments and so so get
that
under control as soon as possible
because it's like learning a language uh
to do
to to produce great works and express
yourself fluently and with confidence
uh it should be your native language
these things should be like your native
language so you're not you're not
wondering
um what is a derivative this is just
part of your
you know part it's it's uh it's in your
bones so to speak you know
and the sooner that you can do that then
the the better so
those all those things can be done in
parallel and should be
you